hello and welcome to this video playing
fatigue okay
Tatia
okay playing the pills no I got a fully
door
yeah the close to lead off with age six
now see I'm going form that what's that
called the lion setup okay that is
usually you could recipe okay g6 just
stopping it
okay now black has a bit of an issue
with castling oh my goodness
I am okay I mean that citizen that is an
idea I don't think it's good but it is
an idea
this is g5 setup I know it's in books
and in DVDs and so on but Queen d3
putting a night on g3 and you're asking
black what is what is your King doing
there why is a 5-week and so on it's not
I mean in a blitz game you can do many
things but I don't think it's a really
good opening so what's going on here if
I take them and here
now how do you cover a five and black is
not exactly developing with with this
opening 97 I take a form
hmm yeah what now Bishop d6 I take F
form I don't see how he save some v5
yeah but this is not yeah the kind of
thing you would like to play the only
question is do I just take a five
I mean that that is going to be a huge
advantage but you can also you can play
Bishop f71 and you know this is just a
simple and strong he has to take the
Queen only five the rook on h8 is just
hanging
kind of stunt that it's not playing it
what I understand the rook is saying was
chick
that's motive the the idea quincy free
nobody has played perform again
lesson learned or something yeah iiii
had this motif on the board when i when
I analyze this for white
no image it's just a reckoning okay I
could take f7 but this is just a strong
move as well 93 I mean yeah come on
that's a good move
it's just it's just overloaded Jim the
knight cannot move the bishop
yeah I'm threatening to take and there's
the issue of the time as well and um an
interesting thing I'm not sure if I did
it perfectly of course but what what is
useful to remember is that in those in
those in those lines where black delays
on castling yeah you have you always
have useful moves in routine one a for
Bishop a - those moves are always useful
and the bishop is getting out of harm's
way a for prevents b5 and so on and if
they gonna evade
usually this is strong preventing
ninety-six and now it's very difficult
for black to - to continue in a decent
way this sucks this also doesn't feel
right
so g6 and then you'd simply step back
you don't have to do it if I remember
correctly white can keep its Knight
there for a moment but it's not bad to
go back and if they go g5 the key idea
to remember is almost always a good idea
is Queen d3 and this night it to
maneuver because the knight is not well
once you three M it is just looking at
dead spots and the Queen covers the
square it makes this possible in some
cases and this is a natural follow-up
this is the only thing you need to know
how to fight against the setup with with
the with the early g5 I think white is
better he does not need to be as much
better as I was in the game but this is
just killing yeah you know you see that
this is this is the I played the top
computer night I sort of remembered this
idea and this played it quite quickly
now now black has no move 97 you take
him and you get killed here as well
after Queen c3 it's basically basically
over
so it's um he has to take then yeah with
this with any five and hmm
I mean it's it's kind of that looks
quite ridiculous now if the if the
center is opened up so what black has to
do is he has to keep the tension down
but white has used four moves you can
always go Knight g3 and then go from
there it's just quite comfortable yeah
okay guys thanks for watching